this is a really good question
okay so
if the citizens of Kansas
enshrined abortion rights into their state constitution
then how come the attorney general of Kansas is currently one of the plaintiffs
suing the FDA to try to restrict mifepristone,
a common and safe abortion medication, for all American women
including women in Kansas
I say restrict there but more accurately
they're effectively trying to ban it
because some of the restrictions
for example that you would need three in person appointments
before your seventh week of pregnancy
like nobody would be able to do that
nobody is going to be able to access this drug anyways
in response to your question
the attorney general of Kansas would say well
you can still get abortions in Kansas
I'm not necessarily trying to restrict your access to abortion
I just have a duty to protect you from this harmful drug
that the FDA wrongfully approved
even though mifepristone is a very safe drug
it is safer than Tylenol it's safer than Viagra
and it is far safer than forest childbirth
it's kind of like when we had the Protection of Roe v
Wade and Republicans would always try to come up with unnecessary hurdles
to try to block women from accessing abortions
under the guise of saying that they're just protecting women and girls
with common safe restrictions